Gusterson Las Vegas hey Gus welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave pleasure to
speak with you
you too man what's up so my wife and I
have about 16,000 dollars in savings and
24,000 and debts we want to fix our
house up a bit so I'd like to get your
advice on how much we should put towards
the debt and how much we should do
support the house we're not I would not
fix up your house until you're out of
that completely yes sir okay so should I
just keep the one thousand in the
emergency fund and yes sir the rest and
that leaves you nine thousand dollars to
pay off what is your household income
about eighty to ninety thousand how fast
can you pay off nine thousand after the
sixteen after you put after you put
fifteen down you got one left that
leaves you 9 how fast can you pay off
nine oh nine months definitely I think
it's half that beans and rice rice and
beans you need to be out of debt then
you rebuild your emergency fund and then
you save up and pay cash for your
repairs what kind of repairs are you
wanting to do what will they cost well
it's just minor so furniture and you
know some painting and our floor
eventually okay run out a a line-item on
it and put it in order which thing would
I do first and what would it cost which
thing would I do second what would it
cost which thing what I do third and
what would it cost and then you have an
emergency fund in your house is probably
15 to 20 thousand fully funded and so
you need nine thousand plus fifteen
thousand plus the cost of these items
and then you're done with this part of
the project or this part of the
discussion and you lay all of that out I
think you're done with all of that in
two to three years a completely
renovated house and the way you want it
depending on what your plan on spending
anyway a fully funded emergency fund and
no debt payments how would that feel
that would feel great but it's going to
all I'm saying is if you want to get to
Florida figure out the map right that
detail out your steps we're going to
turn on this road then we're going to
turn on this road then we're going to
turn on this road what are the steps
what are those
dollars when you lay the dollars all out
and you divide them it gives you a
reason to sacrifice going out to eat to
sacrifice going on vacation because
we're going to plow through these things
and you know because I'd rather have X
than Y I'd rather have an emergency fund
and be debt-free then I would go on this
vacation I'd rather have this couch or
this front new living room furniture
rather than do this thing and so you're
always making choices with money because
we don't have infinite money and so when
you lay down an exact path a clear path
and you lay the dollars out it changes
it changes how motivated you are to get
there